foreign
for everybody's favorite segment facts
or your friends let's do it
I told you man
all right so um
I I one of the most common questions I
get
um I get we get lots of questions about
sex intimacy get lots of questions about
mental health
um and over the last year or two one of
the most common questions I get is about
weight loss and all of the drama that
that surrounds weight loss whether it's
um Instagram nonsense or just outdated
stuff or your mom drank Tab and watched
like VHS tapes when you were a kid and
you've just picked up some of those
habits down this whatever is going on uh
so here's the thing
I don't have expertise here
um and so I invited my friend Sal to
Stefano from mind pump he's he's the are
you the leader of the gang cell no no
we're all we're all equal Partners hey
you know who says that the dawn the true
leader says that that that way in case
it all goes down everybody gets shot not
just not just the leader
um I invited my friend uh Sal on just to
ask a question that is coming up later
on in the show and I just wanted his
expertise um Sal is has been a personal
trainer has been a trainer of trainers
and is now one of um the very few voices
I trust out in the world talking about
Fitness and Nutrition
um Sal thank you so much his last minute
call and you're helping me out today and
you're especially helping out our
listeners thank you so much for joining
me man John thanks for having me on it
you guys you know we absolutely love
what you do uh out there and uh when we
met you just uh you're about as genuine
as they come so I of course I jumped to
the opportunity to be able to help you
out or hop on here I appreciate it all
right so here's the question that I I've
got coming in on my show so when you and
I get off the phone this person's gonna
gonna call in and this is their question
that they they typed up and sent to us
um it's from Jay in uh Michigan says I'm
addicted to sugar and I'm making poor
choices with food I'm afraid if I don't
get it under control I'm gonna die early
or end up on that show my 600 pound life
how can I get get a gauge on this and
change my life
so
the first question I want to ask you Sal
is what's the what's the truth or drama
around sugar addiction I talk about it
all the time like I like I'm some kind
of heroin addict and I I feel often that
I do have a sugar addiction but I don't
even know if that's real man so you have
any wisdom there
yeah um I mean technically you can
develop an addictive
relationship with almost anything now I
know the way that they try to explain
or describe addictive substances is
through the physiological responses
things like dopamine and serotonin and
but I mean you can develop a
dysfunctional relationship that would
mirror what we would consider classic
addiction with almost anything
and food is definitely up there and I
think foods that are hyper palatable or
bring us Comfort or help numb us or
maybe we have some other I don't know
connection to a particular type of food
are probably the ones that are most most
likely
um for us to contr to develop these
behaviors with but you know what are the
Hallmarks of addiction is that you it is
dramatically decreasing the quality of
your life and you continue to do it um
anyway now in that category I mean I
think a lot of people a good chunk of us
have some type of uh dysfunctional
relationship with food this is why
obesity is such such a common thing um
and you know soon here I think it'll be
a majority of Americans yeah so it's
it's a it's a real thing it's really
challenging
um but the approach that we tend to have
towards diet in general is is terrible
it fails it's I think the fail rate last
time I checked was north of 85 percent
and this is like within the first couple
years and I bet you it's closer to 95 if
you stretch it out uh far enough so it's
the approach the approach is all wrong
we focus on the physiological we focus
on the the weight loss and I know those
are all things that people are looking
for but it goes much deeper than that
um
so the the joke that's not really a joke
is I've always said getting off of sugar
stopping uh um sugar Cravings or just
not grabbing candy all the time is is
challenging because nobody I'll say
nobody most work environments don't have
you know joints and cocaine laid out
next to the coffee in the morning like
they do donuts and gummy bears and so
it's pervasive it's everywhere right
um
there's that but there's also like you
mentioned this approach and so that's my
second question here is somebody calls
and says
I can't stop
my my
tough love approach is to to look
somebody in the eye and and put my hands
on the shoulders and say yes you can
but I think that that's just a
derivative of the meta narrative which
is if you're overweight it's because
you're lazy and you're a bum and you
just don't want it bad enough there's
got to be another way to to communicate
love and connectivity and here's what
health looks like what's the path man
yeah it's um it's 100 true it's um it'd
be like looking at you know talking to
somebody who struggles with their
finances and just saying well just make
more money and save more money it's like
well yeah duh
um I guess the steps
can can seem simple but how we get to
those steps
um and how we're able to maintain those
steps
is very complicated so I'll start with
this
um we typically modern societies we
don't eat because we're hungry most
people have never really even felt what
true hunger feels like most people never
go a day without food
so the relationships that we build
around food are based off of lots of
other things
um stress anxiety connecting with people
celebrating boredom uh just hedonistic
pleasure so these are the types of
relationships that we build around food
so just to Simply say to yourself don't
eat that eat this
that might work for very robotic type
fanatical individuals who end up working
in the fitness industry
that doesn't work that doesn't work for
most people so you have to and this is
going to sound a bit esoteric and out
there but I can give people steps to
kind of get to this place but
you have to understand why you're eating
the way you're eating
what does that food make you feel how
can we get that feeling otherwise and
also what is motivating you and if if
what's motivating you is
uh I'm gross I'm fat
um you know I don't look good
um you know anything negative along
those lines it's not going to stick it's
just not going to stick because if
you're doing this because you're gross
fat unattractive inadequate then not
eating food is going to feel restrictive
or not eating the foods that you enjoy
or whatever that relationship is with
that food is going to feel restrictive
and then along those lines exercise is
going to feel like a punishment right
you have to go about it by understanding
that the reason why you're going to
choose to eat the way that you're now
going to eat
is because you're caring for yourself
okay now I say you're doing this because
you love yourself but the reason why I
said care is because when I say love
people think it's a it's the feeling of
love like this warm fuzzy feeling
um but no I mean the action right like I
have kids John and uh look sometimes I
don't get that warm fuzzy feeling for
them teenage kids
dude sometimes I don't feel that feeling
sometimes I'm like man you're pushing it
buddy but I choose to love them yeah
through action so if you say to yourself
I'm going to care for myself like
somebody I care about what does that
look like and start there
then eating right it doesn't feel
restrictive it's self-care and and
that's a much more balanced long-term
approach and it doesn't result or it
typically doesn't result in the
Rebellion that we tend to see when
people do it from a place of self-hate
because when people do it from a place
of self-hate what happens when they go
off a diet right they don't just eat one
cookie or one slice of pizza they ate
the whole box so they eat a whole pizza
until they until they're uncomfortable
it's they Rebel they're rebelling from
the self-hate right so so it's got to
come from a place of self-care that's
number one if you don't do that nothing
else I'm going to say is going to make
sense no diet is going to work for you
no structured anything's gonna work for
you you got to go from a point of
self-care now if you start there then we
can talk about the steps and what that
looks like and how we can develop the
skills that go along with that what
those skills look like because they are
skills you do have to develop them you
do have to learn how to live in this
Society where there's all kinds of
amazing incredible foods that we're
surrounded by that are super easy to get
to
um and inexpensive but you got to start
from a place of self-care that's
incredible man
um
gosh and
that's a tough
um
I'm just thinking here mechanistically
that's that's a tough message
today
um
because
everybody's at war with themselves I
know very few people who are truly happy
with what they see in the mirror and
even more so I know a few people who are
truly happy with their a lot in life you
and I were just joking before we got on
here like that you and I like
we like we like our lives right I I
didn't understand and I liked my life
when I was in other jobs before I took
this I didn't realize how rare that was
and so but
the actual going to the gym the actual
being mindful of what you're putting in
your body those actions are the same so
what you're saying is we just got to
burn a different kind of fuel I always
tell folks man if you're if you're if
you are trying to change your mental
health it's trying to stop drinking
because you're gonna show them you got
about six months on that one right
that's just jet fuel and it burns out
real fast and so what you're saying is
no we may end up doing a lot of the same
stuff
but you gotta have a different feel that
you're burning it's got to be because
you're worth it yes and you gotta look I
I totally understand I have all the
compassion and empathy in the world for
this challenge because
first off uh the reason why this is so
hard John is because
who knows you better than you right I
know all my terrible thoughts I know all
the bad things I I do or want to do I
know all my imperfections like how could
I possibly
love myself like I love my kids right
like I know how all these bad tendencies
that I have you know you very well but
that's again it's not the feeling
it's the it's the can I let me take care
of myself and it's also not necessarily
look in the mirror and being happy with
what you see
you don't have to lie to yourself this
isn't like you know if I can look in the
mirror and I can say to myself man
I really haven't taken care of myself
like uh somebody that deserves to be
cared for and I can tell I can tell I
haven't taken care of myself but I
deserve I deserve to be cared for so I'm
going to try doing that now that's
really all it is I like that I deserve
to be careful and it's that that care
starts with me no one's I I can't
Outsource that that's I've got to decide
I'm worthy of care so where do you tell
somebody who's
um like when I'm just looking across the
the
the buffet of choices here does somebody
start with a counselor does somebody
start with a medical doctor to somebody
start with a personal trainer like where
do you start
if you were to hire if you were in this
situation and you were to hire
um a professional
in my experience the best success I ever
had was when because I was a trainer
okay so I knew exercise and I knew
nutrition from uh calorie macro nutrient
micronutrient you know performance and
then later on I got better at
understanding things like food
intolerances and that kind of stuff so
if I had a client who hired me
and also worked with a therapist
and the therapist and I could work
together the success rate was
astronomical astronomical I love it and
because I'm not a therapist so I can
talk about exercise I could talk about
diet but the therapist is is an expert
and the other things that we need to
work on and then we would talk together
and we would work with this person
together to develop
um some of the strategies that would
help and one thing I'll tell you John
just give an example one thing I learned
from a therapist this is a psychology
thing
people don't like to take things away or
feel restricted but they don't mind
adding things they don't mind adding
things so I'll give you an example
I could say to somebody
um I don't want you to take anything out
of your diet right now
I just want you to try to hit these
protein targets and I'd give them a goal
okay let's I want you to eat 120 grams
of protein a day don't cut anything else
out of your diet but when you eat your
your meals make sure you eat the protein
first and then you could eat everything
else now why does that work
because in the science well 100 support
this the data is very clear
protein produces tremendous satiety yeah
so when they get those protein targets
they would almost always eat less
calories but I didn't tell them to eat
less calories I just told them need
protein so uh you know this is just one
this is one thing I learned from working
with a therapist
or working with therapists on how to
make this a much more effective strategy
because the look we can't we can't
separate the physio the physiological
from the psychological they're both
they're both closely connected amen dude
yeah yeah and what we try to focus on
what we focus on too much
with diet and exercise and all that
stuff is the physiological what's the
best diet what produces the best fat
loss muscle gain insulin response this
that and the other meanwhile every diet
John every diet has a fail rate that's
north of 85 I don't care what it is so
it's not we're not messing up with the
physiological aspect it's the other part
that that every time I I talk to you I
walk away with something new that I just
put in my back pocket that's huge right
there
that that
at some point we have to realize it's
not the math problem that's busted it's
the way we're approaching the problem
um 100 100 and food is a hard one uh you
you know you mentioned something that
was hard about it in that um it's
it's uh we have to eat it it's widely
accepted to eat in in lots of different
ways and we don't learn to eat uh we
don't learn the skills
that help us lead a healthy
life in modern society we just don't we
what ended up happening is in a very
short period of time within Generations
John we went from food is scarce and
hard to come by to there's so much food
and so much variety and so many choices
that it's crazy so we have the the we
learned the skills to to to survive it's
like my parents and my grandparents
right where they you better finish all
your meal you know your food or whatever
like that that right there was mostly
human history now it's like food is
everywhere we just don't we haven't
learned these so we grew up without any
of these skills like how do we navigate
a life
or in a world where there's so much
delicious tasty convenient incredible
cheap
food if we don't have the skills to to
navigate it so it's it's no wonder well
I love what you that word is is Magic
and it's it's been magic with married
couples and with parents
um who
you know can't stop yelling at their kid
or they think they can't stop yelling at
their kids or they snap at their loved
ones
when you reframe it from hey you're not
a terrible human being with no character
you don't have you need some new skills
There's Something Magic about that that
it unhooks all of this extra
psychological baggage that we have and
it's like oh cool okay I can learn to
shoot a free throw if given enough time
um I can learn then these new set of
skills I love that reframe hey I'm Gonna
Let You Go dude you are a saint like
always thank you for
um this is a last second Hail Mary and
you caught the ball so I'm grateful for
you and like always I'm really grateful
for your wisdom and just the Practical
care with which you take care of human
beings who come to you and say hey
please help especially on a touchy
subject like this thank you so much man
I appreciate I appreciate it John you're
a special person I appreciate uh you
having me on so thank you all right take
care good man appreciate it